[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory today
we're going to be discussing severus
snape gaelic grindelwald spell creation
the chilean and the latest fantastic
beasts film the secrets of dumbledore ok
the titles probably confuse you to no
end but to be fair it probably should
because the topic today's video is
centered around is all over the place
the focus of today's video is a scene
from the secrets of dumbledore that
contradicts harry potter canon as we
know it
well at least that's what it looks like
this video idea was actually sent to me
by one of my instagram followers so a
big shout out to will's hep on ig for
bringing it to my attention
go follow me on ig at hp theory if you
aren't following already
this video is going to contain spoilers
for the secrets of dumbledore so if you
haven't seen it yet then come back later
grindelwald's acolytes have captured the
fabled chillin a mythical creature
involved in the wizarding election
process
essentially the chilean is able to
recognize those that are truly pure of
heart this makes it a perfect asset in
helping to select a new wizarding world
leader however this doesn't work quite
so well when the process is tampered
with or more specifically when the
chilean is tampered with
after capturing the chilean it's not
long before grindelwald cuts its throat
you see grindelwald had plans to
reanimate the chilean's corpse as a sort
of in fairy he wanted a chilling that
was guaranteed to pick him
but provided the reanimated chillin
would need to be devoid of scars as to
not draw attention grindelwald needed to
heal any physical marks left on the
chillin's body
it's at this point in time that he uses
a spell we have seen before
vulneras and in tor
seemingly this spell was part of
grindelwald's necromancy ritual where
the chilean was revived but where have
we seen vulneras and in tour before
why spouted out of the mouth of severus
snape of course
and before the secrets of dumbledore we
harry potter fans knew the spell as the
counter curse for snape's signature
spell and his own creation sektum sempra
we first see sektum sempra in the films
when harry uses it on malfoy in the
half-blood prince the name sektum sempra
comes from the combination of two latin
words sectus which means having been cut
and semper which means always zectum's
emperor is a vicious dark curse that
acts like an invisible sword causing
lacerations hemorrhaging and cuts upon
its target
often after being struck the target will
lay there motionless as they lose blood
it is somewhat of a specialty of snapes
and is featured in his textbook for
advanced potion making
after harry discovers sectim's emperor
he first uses it on malfoy blood spurted
from alford's face and chest as though
he'd been slashed with an invisible
sword he staggered backward and
collapsed onto the waterlogged floor
with a great splash his wand falling
from his limp right hand
slipping and staggering harry got to his
feet and plunged toward malfoy whose
face was now shining scarlet his white
hand scrabbling at his blood-soaked
chest due to this spell's intrinsic
ability to cause extreme damage to a
target a counter-curse seems like a safe
bet
bolnera comes from the latin vulners
which means wound and senentor comes
from the latin sanaa which means to heal
volnera senentor is the only known
defense treatment for sectim sempra and
it's used to ease the blood flow heal
the wound and remove the effects of the
curse
for vulnerable to be used most
efficiently it has been expressed that
the incantation has to be repeated three
times
the first time the incantation is
uttered it eases the flow of blood the
second time it's uttered it begins to
heal the wounds
and the third time it's uttered the
wounds will be fully healed
in order to prevent scarring it's also
necessary to use dittony which is a
magical plant used in potion making it's
a powerful and restorative healing herb
that makes fresh skin grow over a wound
the use of vulnerable is described in
the following excerpt he knelt over
malfoy drew his wand and traced it over
the deep wounds harry's curse had made
muttering in incantation sounded almost
like song
the flow of blood seemed to ease snape
wiped the residue from malfoy's face and
repeated his spell
now the wounds seemed to be knitting up
until this point everyone thought snape
was responsible for inventing vulnera
centaur and the glaring problem with
grindelwald using it is that grindelwald
used it in 1932
28 years before snape was born
now it's generally accepted that snape
invented the spell and this is supported
primarily by the fact that it's the
solitary counter curse for an offensive
curse that we know he created during the
battle of the seven potters snape
attempted to use the curse to sever the
hand of a fellow death eater
but due to a slip he accidentally cut
off george weasley's left ear instead
the following exchange between remus and
hermione explains this he lost an ear
lost in snape's work
judging by the fact that they almost
immediately recognized this as snape's
work i feel as though it supports the
fact that snape created the spell we
also know that snape loved inventing
spells
in fact he's credited with inventing
sektum sempra vulnera senentor
levocorpus liberacorpus the mafiatocharm
langlock and the toenail growing hex
here's what i think a young snape driven
to excel in magic began researching
anything and everything he could find
related to powerful magic much like tom
riddle during his inquisitive search for
powerful magic like horcruxes sirius
black once remarked on snape's tenacity
when it came to research on curses
he knew more curses when he arrived at
school than half the kids in seventh
year
amidst his research snape came across a
text referencing magic used by powerful
dark wizard gelet grindelwald
snape knew that he was a powerful and
influential figure so it makes sense
that he would try to learn from him why
not learn from the best it's here that
he found vulneras and in tor and while
snape saw no use for volnera sinentor in
its current form aiding and reanimating
dead corpses
he decided that he could modify the
spell for his own usage
at this point it became a counter-curse
for sectim's emperor
it's also worth mentioning that the way
grindelwald and snape use the spell is
quite different
furthermore snape's version of the spell
requires the use of ditkani to prevent
scarring my other theory is this
dumbledore taught snape the spell
dumbledore wasn't an idiot and he
probably knew very well that as a
student snape was a gifted
and b creating all sorts of horrific
offensive spells snape in his youth was
entirely focused on doing as much damage
as possible learning offensive curse
after offensive curse
he was bullied relentlessly in school
and he had a chip on his shoulder a
point to prove and this prompted him to
learn spells which could help him enact
his revenge
dumbledore recognized snape's potential
but also his propensity to do damage
which prompted him to try and guide
snape in the right direction
he didn't want snape to do something
that he would regret without any sort of
escape route
dumbledore who happened to know gaelic
grindelwald extremely well was aware of
both grindelwald's and snape's spells
which is why he was able to recognize
that with a bit of tweaking vulnera
celentor could be the perfect
counter-curse for snape
either that or the secrets of dumbledore
just totally tore apart a bit of cannon
what do you guys think leave a comment
down below until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you